thank you so much for inviting e.t to
your home the two of you montez and
bianca y'all met at wwe
we only wear gold in this house the
first time i saw him i was telling my
friends i was like oh that's it that is
a beautiful man
so
one night i don't know where he just
turns to me he's like i like your makeup
what a pickup line
so like i was nervous ooh i love how you
look at her
seriously seriously like she like brings
me back back excuse me i can't even talk
just make you nervous yes yes she
trained me well
actually as i saw they train each other
they work out up to six days a week in
their home gym preparing for tomorrow's
summer slam streaming on peacocks
this is the title that i wanted
wrestlemania it's pretty heavy bianca i
think we both need to rock a belt look
at us
don't mess with us gal
so when you get in the ring what are
your signature moves you tell what yours
is sure it's the uh it's called the kod
which is called the kiss of death kiss
the death
[Applause]
you ever pulled out the kod over here on
our
tez
i just want to knock him off his feet
watch you ready yeah yeah
he's out
my signature move is the frog splash
everything's bigger in texas so
basically you've been kissing a frog
folks like dwayne the rock johnson john
cena they got their start in wwe
who were some folks that you would like
to see make their way back into the ring
i would definitely say
dwayne johnson would be nice to share
the ring with him
well the rock is also a fan of montez
and told me challenge accepted i love
that guy i love his energy i love his
charisma i love his work ethic he wants
to see dj back in the ring could it ever
happen of course yeah thank you
the rock dwayne johnson for that um
he was someone i watched as a kid
growing up he's idle someone i look up
to like i always tip my hat off to him
[Music]